les chers compatriotes je suis heureux
de vous dire ce soir
les voeux très sincères que je forme
pour vous et pour tous ceux que vous
aimez beaucoup d'entre vous sont en
famille et s'apprête à fêter la nouvelle
année
d'autres sont seuls malades ou dans la
peine et ma première pensée une pensée
chaleureuse sera pauvre en 1997 une
nouvelle majorité a été je vais donc
nous mais un ministre issu de cette
majorité le gouvernement applique sa
politique et je vais vous dire comment
les choses se présentent
conformément à la lettre l'esprit de nos
institutions
j'assume dans leur paie ni tude les
pouvoirs et les devoirs de ma charge
garant de la continuité de l'état
je suis aussi le gardien des valeurs de
la république au premier rang desquels
la liberté et la solidarité responsable
de l'avenir de la nation
j'interviendrai chaque fois que ses
intérêts seront en jeu pour vous dire ce
que je crois être bon pour les français
ou au contraire dangereux pour notre
pays
vingt-quatre mois seulement nous
séparent de landais le temps s'accélère
les échanges se multiplient les
mentalités évoluent les frontières
s'estompent
nous vivons c'est vrai des temps
incertains et difficiles mais qui ne
voit que ce sont aussi des temps riche
de promesses riche de possibilités pour
autant que l'on sache que l'on veuille
les saisies et à l'eau de cette année
une belle je voudrais dans cet esprit
formulé deux
ve pour la france le souhaite d'abord
une france rassemblée à corte dont les
citoyens vivent en bonne intelligence
cela veut dire d'abord une france
rassuré il n'y a chez nous trop de
violence trop d'insécurité dans les
écoles dans les transports dans les rues
chaque jour des limites sont franchies
au delà desquels en quelque sorte la
société sud est fait et c'est
aujourd'hui je le sais avec une chômage
notre premier souci l'état pour jouer
tout son rôle il doit s'efforcer de
mieux comprendre il doit à prévenir
il doit aussi punir quand il le faut et
j'appelle chacun à prendre ses
responsabilités que les citoyens
respectent leurs devoirs que les
pouvoirs publics restent hors l'ordre et
la sécurité qui est la première des
libertés
une france rassemblée c'est aussi une
france fière de ses valeurs la dignité
des hommes et des femmes bien sûr la
protection des enfants mais aussi la
laïcité et l'intégration
l'idéal de tolérance auquel nous sommes
tous profondément attachés ne doit pas
nous conduire à accepter ce qui met en
péril l'unité de la nation
notre pays n'est pas et ne sera jamais
l'addition de communautés juxtaposés le
bien public n'est pas et ne sera jamais
l'addition d'intérêts particuliers enfin
une france rassemblée c'est une france
qui se parlent
qui sait écouter qui sait pratiquer
l'échangé le dialogue qui sait anticiper
les évolutions nécessaires et les
conduire dans la concertation
la modernité n'est pas un champ de
bataille avec des gagnants et des
perdants
chacun peut et doit y trouver des avants
pour cela discutons dépassons nos
contradictions et nos querelles
inventons des solutions nouvelles
je vous convie tout ardemment à mieux
faire vivre notre démocratie
le deuxième feu c'est une france qui a
davantage fois en l2 nous avons toutes
les raisons d'être fiers de notre patrie
et de croire notre avenir
cet avenir notre avenir et chaque jour
construit et fortifiés par des hommes
des femmes des jeunes surtout avides de
comprendre et de créer il s'appuie sur
notre vaste culture sans cesse à jenny
est enrichi par des connaissances
nouvelles
il s'exprime dans des sciences et des
technologies peu je veux toujours plus
vivace et qu'une démocratie plus
exigeantes doit préserver de l'excès et
puis il ya l'europe
cette europe qu après d'autres et avec
d'autres je contribue à bâtir le fait
pour garantir la paix un continent que
l'histoire a trop souvent brutalisés et
trop longtemps divisé je le fais pour
assurer sa puissance et sa prospérité au
service de tous je le fais parce que je
sais que nous pouvons y être les
meilleurs nous le pouvons si nous
changeons dans nos têtes
il n'y a pas d'exception française qui
nous permettrait de nous soustraire aux
règles qui valent pour les autres mais
il doit y avoir une ambition française
libérer les forces les énergies de notre
peuple
créer les conditions de la richesse et
de l'activité pour que tous les français
en profite pour que nous puissions créer
les emplois qui manquent et faire
reculer le chômage qui frappe si
durement tant d'entre nous et l'on voit
bien encore aujourd'hui la gravité et
l'acuité de ce drame
lutter plus efficacement contre
l'exclusion que personne ne reste au
bord du chemin
il est là notre rêve de dignité et de
grandeur plus vivant que jamais et nous
en ferons une réalité dans la vie d'un
pays il y à des temps de joie et de
tristesse d'espoir et d'inquiétude des
séparations des retrouve un mais
l'important c'est de préserver ce qui
fait la force d'une famille d'entre
elles la chaleur le soutien le plaisir
d'être ensemble et d'avancer ensemble
une nation c'est la chance de vivre et
d'appartenir à une communauté unie par
son histoire et par sa culture c'est
construire un avenir pour nos mes chers
compatriotes de métropole et d'outre-mer
de l'étranger soyons fiers
soyons heureux d'être français et ayons
confiance en le souhaite à chacune et à
chacun d'entre vous une très très bonne
année et la république et vive